since QQ solutions yogi paid chef and
the other fishermen here are not happy
their nets are torn up again and they
know who's to blame you money Jeff quit
damages look a dolphin made this whole
look at the big holes the dolphins made
these were made by little dolphins
hustled mom keep the dough fini Terre
Yemeni she says she did the year before
last it took me a month to mend all the
Nets just because of the dolphins
sometimes the holes are as big as a
whole boat or a door or a car the
fishermen in sorry vose harbour are
convinced there are too many dolphins in
the black sea they say they have a good
life each dolphin eating some 20 kilos
of fish per day fish Georg you would
like to catch and sell he has no
sympathy for the hundreds of dolphins
found washed up dead on Bulgaria's coast
this year environmentalists blame
large-scale driftnet fishing I was lucky
it's a huge business you can catch 800
kilos of turbot with a three kilometer
long drift net with a hundred-kilometer
net you can haul in two to four times Oh
Sees really advise it one kilo brings up
to 40 euros on the market in turkey's so
you can make half a million euros in
just a few days the dead baby dolphins
washed up here on the beach by the waves
have just been taken out of the nets and
thrown into the sea which the cooks
through
romanian biologist von popescu came to
bulgaria on his own initiative to
support the environmentalists he's going
to conduct a necropsy on this dolphin to
establish the cause of death gmail moves
in creation performed most of them are
stressed because they're not finding
enough food and many get caught up in
fishing nets their nets that have been
cut loose or nets used for turbo there
is also illegal fishing the authorities
have got to crack down on that much
harder ela got cut after we my intense
combat suit many of the Dolphins are
killed in the legal and illegal Nets of
fishermen drift Nets that have been cut
loose known as ghost nets float just
beneath the surface they are especially
treacherous an estimated 1000 kilometers
of ghost nets are adrift in the Black
Sea the fishermen reject any and all
responsibility
that's potentially but the night market
program I think we fishermen are the
least of the black sea dolphins problems
fishing is monitored by at least three
different authorities the maritime
administration the border police and the
fisheries Authority they see everything
that happens at sea on their monitors
yes when they come as a bit annoyed at
this particular day the fisheries
Authority has no illegal fishermen on
their monitor they normally cast their
nets 40 to 50 nautical miles out from
the coast out of reach of the
authorities slow little nun ocean-going
boats but the state doesn't seem willing
to spend any more to fight the illegal
fishing only a few poachers are ever
caught
last year we handed for such cases on to
the state prosecutor
some of the trials are still in progress
we report everything we see and we hope
to stop the poaching completely so far
not a single poacher has been handed a
prison sentence in Bulgaria
environmentalists are calling for a ban
on driftnet fishing they have no doubt
that's what's killing the dolphins this
year the dolphin carcasses that were
suitable for examination were found to
have drowned that can only happen if
they get caught in the fisherman's
illegal nets and can't free themselves
environmentalists have catalogued more
than 400 dead dolphins victims of
unbridled fishing washed up on
Bulgaria's beaches